anthony bellanger il est secrétaire
général de la fédération internationale
des journalistes est signataire de la
lettre adressée au ministre britannique
de la justice
anthony bellanger merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors pourquoi
l'emprisonnement de julian assange et sa
possible extradition sont ils perçus
comme une atteinte au droit d'informer
des journalistes le cas de julian
assange est beaucoup plus large que
celui qu'on connaît réellement c'est que
il est le symbole aujourd'hui d'un
journaliste cherchait son travail celui
d'avoir dénoncé des crimes de guerre
lors des états unis pendant la guerre en
irak et qui a fait des années que la
mort de civils et puis deux journalistes
est le symbole il est il est on est en
train de de nommer quelqu'un de dénoncer
quelqu'un qui a un qui n'a fait que son
travail et il est devenu aujourd'hui
l'ennemi public numéro un de
l'administration américaine puisqu'il a
il a mis au jour des informations
d'intérêt public qui ont été justifiées
par le travail de wikileaks depuis le
depuis tant d'années alors cette affaire
est ce qu'elle ternit l'image du royaume
uni sur la scène internationale oui bien
entendu avec nos affiliés anglais nous
en novembre en angleterre la chesnaie
l'uniopss journalistes on a beaucoup de
contacts avec le avec le gouvernement de
maurice johnson et d'ailleurs il ya
quelques jours le ministre d'état lors
ahmad wimbledon a quand même déclaré que
la liberté des médias était vital pour
les sociétés démocratiques et qu'il a
rappelé que les journalistes doivent
pouvoir enquêter et faire des reportages
en tout en toute liberté donc dire d'un
côté le 8 juin dernier que les journées
ils doivent pouvoir faire leur travail
et de l'autre continuer à maintenir en
détention à un homme qui n'a fait que
son travail s'est dénoncé des faits de
guerre des crimes de guerre la gagne il
ya un gap il ya une il ya un fossé qui
est tellement énorme que au nom de la
fédération internationale on est quand
même très inquiet 2
de la situation de jeu intéressant sauf
général mais aussi de sa situation de
santé se son père me disait encore il ya
quelques jours
john shipton qu'il était épuisé et qu'il
ne tenait réellement que grâce au
soutien de tous ces mouvements de lançon
des ong ou des organisations
internationales comme la nôtre mais
finalement sur quels aspects juridiques
s'appuie le gouvernement américain pour
retenir autant de charges contre le
lanceur d'alerté pour les américains il
il l'aurait violée à un grand nombre de
deux de loi et notamment l'acte de 1917
1 2917 actes et à partir de là il les
considérait quasiment comme un
terroriste et avec des dénonciations de
d'événements qu'il n'aurait jamais dû
aborder dans ses chansons dans son
travail et nous en tant que le
journaliste on rappelle que tous les
journalistes doivent pouvoir faire leur
travail correctement et si tu n'as forme
si l'information devait être fausse
depuis 2010 ce choix que on serait
depuis très longtemps et depuis très
longtemps depuis maintenant 10 ans on
sait que les informations ont été
données et rendue publique par julian
assange sont réels et véridique
donc on est vraiment dans un cas
extrêmement symbolique de tout
simplement de la liberté de base de de
la presse et je rappelle que le premier
droit des citoyens c'est d'être bien
informés et qui doit bien informés
évidemment ce sont les genres mcc c'est
ce à quoi nous nous nous aspirons en
tant que fédération internationale et
pourquoi le royaume-uni est-il angles a
accepté d'extrader julian assange pour
là on est dans un com vous l'avez
compris on est dans des aidants des dans
des schémas politiques et diplomatiques
qui sont largement au dessus de la tête
de julian assange veut dire que que ce
soit d'origine sonne aujourd'hui où ses
prédécesseurs ils sont tellement
impliqué dans les relations avec les
américains qu'ils ne peuvent pas faire
autrement que d'accepter la demande de
donald trump et c'est pour cette raison
la tournée des dizaines et des dizaines
d'organisations internationales à à
maintenir cette pression puisque on est
vraiment dans un cadre de
criminalisation de la formation et c'est
pire qui puisse arriver un homme est le
pire qui puisse arriver un journaliste
est bien entendu le pire qui puisse
arriver à une démocratie comme l'est
aujourd'hui le royaume merci beaucoup
anthony bellanger d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général de la fédération
internationale des journalistes mais
également signataire de la lettre
adressée au ministre britannique de la
justice